[Music]
sunday morning church what's happening
good morning guys what's happening
beautiful a lot of people said to put a
camera on you i said you didn't want a
[__] camera
that you want to be like the neighbor in
the tim allen show or whatever i got
warrants in jerusalem that's right i
hope you guys are doing [__] time
going to spark the [__] holy smoke
the church of what's happening now is in
full [__] effect everything's
beautiful had a great weekend up at the
[__] ice house we did friday we did
saturday
stan hope showed up drinking vodkas i
[__] love that guy
oh that was amazing i watched it this
morning when i got home from work and
it's just when he was talking about
arizona i thought of you i don't think
you're going to move to arizona but just
the entire way he was talking about his
town i could like
with you or tennessee or wherever you'd
go i could imagine you doing that in a
few years [__] you i don't want to you
know it's included and stuff like that
but it's hysterical because what a lot
of people don't know is that doug
stanhope really helped me move to los
angeles about 15 years ago i've known
stanhope since 91 and uh
we've been in boulder at the boulder
broker joker when i was starting to do
comedy at first
and he [__] stayed at my house twice
and uh
he came back he was on evening at the
improv and we became friends and we kept
in touch and then i forgot what you know
i forgot his number some [__] and i was
living in seattle by that time
and uh he had one san francisco comedy
competition and he was [__] huge and
he came up and he did new year's and
he asked me to come back to l.a with him
and i was like i don't [__] think so
and then as i was ready to come move
down here from [__] seattle
they uh
they [__] uh didn't want me to leave
like they put like this phony warrant up
so i had to wait an extra [__] couple
weeks but when i got here i stayed with
stan hope he got me into the [__]
comedy story
that's what a lot of people don't know
so i had a great time up there testicle
testaments was great testicle testaments
the taping uh
was great on wednesday night we talked
about juan that was amazing man i mean
it's getting better and better i mean if
you guys don't know joey does his
stories testicle testaments every last
wednesday of the month last wednesday
the month and i i'm very lucky because i
like the week before joey takes me to a
coffee shop and he just
we're just talking but he goes through
this story with me and it's
especially this one about your your
stepdad was just
it was unbelievable
you were you got emotional it it did you
becoming a father now it's kind of
amazing to think i came back it spins
out you know it was weird because uh
he was like my father he was my father
he's only father i ever knew so i always
think about him i find myself doing [__]
in the daytime i'm like that's something
one would do or whatever
but besides that the church was
happening now we're going to come to you
live every [__] week every week twice
a week monday mornings about 6 a.m
wednesday mornings about 6 00 a.m a
little bit of music talking about some
[__] you know talk about the rules of
what's happening now a lot of people
don't know about the church what's
happening now how it was invented church
of what's happening now is a code i
[__] live off okay you have these
people and they come up to you and they
start breaking your balls about [__] and
you listen to what they're telling you
like either this guy's a [__] phony
or he's out of his [__] mind you know
talking to you about well in in in 1972
you know dolphins were going to be
extinct who gives a [__] guy you mean to
tell me you're really interested about
[__] or just talking about this [__] to
be [__] interesting the church of
what's happening now avoids all that
[__] rule number one of the church
always having now is mind your [__]
business rule number two mind your
[__]
rule number three mind your [__]
business what that means all together is
nothing bad will happen if you don't
mind your [__] business that's number
one just mind it number two of the
church was having now whatever they
think they expecting from you give them
something [__] different if they're
expecting a night poke kick them in the
[__] ear or kick him in the nut sack
or something
something completely different here look
at these twitter [__] monkey toddies
or savage these [__] don't
sleep on twitter you know what it's
amazing i just they're up all night i'm
up all night it's crazy especially with
you with 70 000 followers i come home at
one of the [__] morning you just put
say hello on there there's 92 million
[__] hits on there it's amazing yeah
it's we created our own little [__]
world with the internet and i hated it
for a long time because a bunch of young
kids on there playing the drama
and it's amazing because we wouldn't be
here without them we started out with
mad flavors world we did the cd we did
the documentary [__] facebook look at
the stock is going down facebook's full
of [__] ads you can smell the twins
on there what are those two twins doing
then they buy a house they sell in the
house and oh the winklevoss twins oh god
winky voss twins these [__] momos
i'm surprised you even knew about them i
tried to think of who you're talking
about what the [__] you think you're
dealing with dog i've seen social
network [__]
i've seen it a couple of times i can't
put up with the guy that plays the thief
i like uh justin timberlake i think
what's the kid's name that plays the
[__] thing oh
jesse eisenberg yeah he always has a
look on his face like somebody [__]
farted oh speaking about [__] farting
we finished the podcast the other day
let's go get some [__] coffee or
something now the whole morning you know
before you before you need to [__] like
we're getting up early right now so i'm
not even in my [__] zone the [__] sold
starts about 7 30 quarterly right before
church
so it's early so i i gotta eat breakfast
first drink a few cups of coffee maybe
smoke a number and i'm ready to take a
[__] dumpster and i walk outside with
lee
and i had to rip one i didn't want to go
in this car you have somebody farting
and bringing the [__] fart until
they're [__] into your car nothing
pisses me off more than that when
somebody farts in the hallway and they
bring it in air it out out there so i
blow this [__] tremendous [__] i'm
gonna blow right now listen
just like that i blow up where's the
number
but you can't he lee heard it in the car
oh my god i heard in the car a [__]
real jew i'm not gonna go in there with
that ass stink around my muffler i'm out
there airing the leg out i'm pumping it
like a [__] dog and as i look i see a
lady about 30 feet away and she's about
90 years old like a spanish grandmother
and she's blocking it slowly like
picture any old woman walking across the
street that's her i get into the [__]
car and i go leave this poor lady's
about to walk into the fog of [__]
death
and sure enough as she walks into the
zone i see her pick her head up and just
start going like this like she smells it
and she made a face that was perfect
perfect now if you were inside the house
and somebody smelled jafar that's one
thing but when you're outside this
horror film it sucks up the farts and
[__] like that you still bump into a
fart that was a [__] good fight what
about the one i just kicked right now oh
my god there's no you're gonna have to
throw that chair out but that it didn't
what you just said they didn't even give
it justice that woman her face turned up
and she was waving at the air like it
was mustard gas or something it wasn't
just oh that's a bad smelling part she
was you probably ruined her day let me
tell you something people i hope you're
up don't forget let's say church starts
at 7 30. it's 6 18 right now it's 9 18
on the east coast either you're walking
out of church you're going to [__]
denny's to stand online like a mook
or you're going to go through your car
smoke a number and think about whatever
the [__] the priest or the [__]
deacon or the [__] rabbi had to say
well the jews go to church yesterday
whatever the [__] temple
that's special they go to temple with
prince
so
like right now today i gotta get the
[__] out of here but now
i'll go in there i see padre throw a
[__] blessing on him
put a couple dollars in the basket i'm
out of that [__] half hour but who
else comes on before church to get you
ready mentally for what the [__] they're
gonna talk about only joey diaz like
today what the [__] they're gonna talk
about [__] peter and paul i don't
give a [__] i've heard the story 80
times but i go
i take a couple rips off this and i said
it's all over but the [__] shot and
the funny thing was
now that's tremendous loving the church
of what's happening now i heard the fart
here in wales
technology you understand me that's how
my muffin i got people always say joey
speak closer to the [__] microphone
these are tight [__] microphones you
can talk anywhere in the room they get
you it's like a [__] fbi microphone
jesus christ speaking of which man let
me tell you something i watch some
college football what a lot of people
don't know is one of the kids i
grew up with is now the uh the head
defensive coordinator of penn state
jesus christ
of uh miami really yeah they [__] won
big yesterday that was pretty good i
watched that for a little while but
there's no pro today right no no it
starts next week now let me explain
something to you if see if you let's say
you're a pro [__] gambler
professional gambler you're getting up
right now the first game could be a two
who gives a [__] you're getting up now
you're gonna get your day started you're
gonna look at the paper you're gonna go
online see who's hurt you're gonna do
some [__] voodoo maybe throw a curse
on the [__] quarterback and you're up
early [__] watching those dumb tv shows
they're steering you to a [__] loser
those [__] they're kissing that
you don't see them putting no [__]
bets on nothing
so now you're getting up you're getting
early that [__] don't start this week
next week is the [__] killer all
these nfl junkie [__]
will be up ready to rock where's my
cat's at these [__]
these are the treats they like right
here [__] temptations it tastes like
milk or whatever they got all different
flavors
nobody's getting conned into this [__]
these little [__] they got up
early with me i got up there was like
two of them up already
oh yeah you said they're up all night
well they're up all night if they get
encouragement i'd like four they tap out
they go [__] there's nobody here to
rock the house was uncle joey
but i tell you what you have no idea
when you come home and now you have cats
because this [__] listen my
wife goes to bed at nine o'clock it's
not even my wife i'm worried about the
[__] cats i come home i got a female
cat that just sits there and harasses me
you want to lower that [__] in there
what are you gonna do things have been
things are
get over here what are you little
[__] get over here and [__] i got
treats i'm giving out
come here baby come here
temptation streets i got the [__]
check this [__] out i got oh
[__]
there's my boy see he's all scared to me
i don't know what he's probably going to
do
yeah once one comes in they all come in
yeah no they come and they see me now
the one guy's nervous you should have
called me i would have opened the door
for you when you're knocking he goes
[__] bananas oh okay come here harry
say hello to the people at home cause i
can come here knuckle sandwich get over
here
this is what happens early in the
morning you gotta say hello to the cats
the animals another thing it's [__]
sunday so don't forget to get your
oatmeal you want to start the week off
right with the muffler you know i'm
saying come here come say hello to the
[__] people
i love this little guy here
don't forget if you want to drive your
cat's crazy right here it's on uh amazon
it's called pet green catnip buds these
buds look [__] good too
thank god i don't drink i come home and
[__] roll one of these things up look
at this
it's not a [__] tree or something
like that
so speaking of opium one of the things
we want to talk about is losing weight
that's right joey's lost a lot of weight
and you guys can't see me but i've lost
about 40 pounds but i need to lose about
another 100 something like that and
joey's been one of the best guys for me
since we've gotten together
taking me through it because like the
usual diet i'm sure a lot of guys out
there listening or girls right now
listening have weight issues and a lot
of the diets and weight when working out
it just sucks so joey has the oatmeal
what else do you usually eat all every
day if you're going to put a banana in
me i'll [__] put a little oatmeal in
me a little special k
and then uh
i go for a little walk about 8 30 when i
take my wife to work and then
as the day goes i'm i'm basically a
weight watchers guy i'm always looking
for new [__] recipes you know i got
the dolce book so listen man uh it's
like my religious beliefs i'm a catholic
but i try to borrow from the [__]
jews i throw a little buddhism in there
you know i'm saying a little santeria i
put it all together it's like the g
kundo of [__] religions this is like
the g kundo of diets so i do the dolce
diet and i do the weight watchers that i
have put together and then you work out
like a [__] and on the other
side you know it's funny because when i
first i was weighing 415
and
for a month i would go box in the
morning and fortune's gym and i'd uh hit
the bag and i'd [__] uh the macca
foley would train me in the in the ring
and i did that for a while i wasn't loot
i lost 15 pounds in 60 days
and then i read something online that
talked about that you could jump up and
down for 92 [__] hours a day
but if you're not uh eating correctly
that's the whole thing you got to eat
correctly and i read it and it made
sense and i had gone to a heart doctor
and that [__] guy said to me you know
he goes joey you've been coming in here
for a while
uh my heart's strong but he goes you
you're too heavy your heart's strong he
goes you should do something why don't
you
go to see uh what's that diet not when
they put the [__] staple in your
stomach but the other one when they oh
stomach gastro bypass because you should
look into it and he goes that he would
he could talk to a doctor and give it to
me at cost and they could do payments
and i said you know what that's about 90
[__] needles
i could see me fainting the whole
[__] week i go forget about that [__]
so before i i looked into it i had a
friend marlon martinez who died a couple
years ago cancer
god bless her soul but uh
she was on weight watchers and she lost
a ton of [__] weight for a while
so i remember just walking into weight
watchers and it was just making little
[__] changes it wasn't like bro let
me tell you something a fat [__] like me
stoner could lose weight anybody could
lose weight because it's basically just
switching it around i i i went from
eating you know this was my old
breakfast my old breakfast was like
three eggs sunny side up a half a pack
of bacon you know toast i had about
three cans of coca-cola that was my old
breakfast yeah it was like whatever what
what i would eat with my wife at uh
at eight o'clock you know 7 30. as soon
as she went to work or i smoked a
[__] joint i go to mcdonald's and get
a number one with a [__] coke cheese
you know and two apple pies and then i'd
smoke more pot and i go eat chinese with
my friends you know and chinese will
[__] uh
fatten you the [__] up you know
especially the chinese
and then i'd go home and eat the
leftovers from the night before
and then i'd have dinner with my wife
now my wife is from the [__] south
you know my wife are fried if you let
her that [__] will fry a [__] piece
of bread
you know so uh
i would go home and she'd make a huge
dinner okay and then i go out
go to the comedy store and i drink
coca-cola's
oh jeez that's killer and i drink 10 or
12 coca-colas you know all night at the
bar with no alcohol in it then i go home
on the way home you got to stop and get
a taco a milkshake or something so it
was really easy so with weight watchers
i went from that diet to basically one
egg
a piece of toast three slices of bacon
and a bowl of oatmeal and a bunch of
fruit see the weight watchers diet i did
before see i i write everything there
so the weight watchers diet i did before
they had fruit it was points but i'm
sitting there going fruits no points
you're pushing this out of your ass so i
cheated i just ate as much fruit as i
could i went from [__] apples to
bananas to to peaches like i just ate a
banana this my
fruit's the key like if you're over 350
pounds weight watcher says to eat fruit
seven [__] times a day and that's
tough man that's tough but not really
that's an apple here a banana there a
pineapple [__] here you know that
that's really tough but you know what i
dropped a hundred pounds i went all the
way to 270.
uh in the last 14 months i've put on
30 pounds i'm up to 300 i walk around at
298 297
by the time the baby's born i'd like to
be down at 250 245 you know my head's
gonna be [__] ginormous
if you think you know my head my nose
all you see is [__] nose and ears
coming at you
and that's one thing they never had to
die for is the [__] coconut yeah and
let me ask you because you're a comic
and you would on the road and being out
at night my big problem is i work a lot
and and the
i would there's nothing easier than a
drive-through after you work eight ten
hours a day you don't really wanna go
home and cook now you're not doing that
but you're out on the road you're out
late at the store you don't wanna come
home and start cooking a meal so you
stop at mcdonald's or whatever
is it just changing your mindset or how
did you get to doing weight watchers
with that sort of stuff
you just have to decide what the [__]
you want to do
you know if you're going to mcdonald's
and all those places you're shooting
yourself in the [__] foot anyway
you're shooting yourself in the [__]
foot if you're going to mcdonald's
constantly you know what i
you have to i don't understand how
mcdonald's is still in business with
everything i read i don't understand how
you got these little [__] kids and i
see him going into mcdonald's one thing
about me guys if you look at my pictures
if i could find pictures of me as a
child that was always scrappy i was
skinny i didn't get [__] fat though
my 35s 32s really yeah i used to walk
everywhere i would walk okay you know i
believe in [__] exercise but i got
what's called sleep apnea one of the
worst things you could [__] do is
stay up late especially if you have to
get up early which is part of your
problem yeah i'm working nights too so
it's it's tough but here it is man plain
and simple it's whatever the [__] you
want to do you want to lose the [__]
way you lose the [__] weight i'm
telling you that it's not hard at all to
[__] lose weight it's harder in your
mind people think it's harder in your
mind because weight watchers teaches you
for example there's a place roma [__]
pizza up here that they make sandwiches
okay
now you could go in there we could get a
sandwich two sides chips and a soda
or you go in there and get split a
sandwich yeah one side of red peppers in
olive oil which you don't think that has
points is the olive oil which is good
for you yeah and maybe get a you know a
glass of water or something you could
still eat i can still go to [__] uh
in and out burger and get a burger a
cheeseburger single with lettuce tomato
no mayonnaise and no [__] special
sauce i could eat a half order of fries
because the burger with the points is
eight i could eat a half order of fries
which is four
and then get a diet soda so i just want
to in and out for 12 pounds as opposed
to two burgers the large burger there's
a double double fries a milkshake or
soda and you know what at first you look
at this meal and you go uh i i'm gonna
be [__] hungry
but
you're not after you finish there
you're not hungry at all you're like
what the [__] man if i could do this all
the time
it wouldn't be that bad you know what
i'm saying yeah one thing you said to me
when we started is going like going to
subway which is
you can get healthy food there but when
you go in there i always think oh i'm
going to want that the foot long
when you eat the foot long you're full
if you hadn't gotten the six inch and
waited 10 minutes you're gonna be full
it's enough food if you eat the six inch
butt let me tell you something man and i
and i'm a [__] uh i've always liked
the best food i always that's one thing
about me my mother did not like let me
eat fast food okay you know i'm from
jersey i had [__] i grew up around great
delis oh yeah i would never let myself
on a [__] like i was in nashville and
there was a subway and i go let me go
get a tuna how bad could the tuna be
it's [__] bad yeah you know i'm
sitting there one day like any other
stoner on [__] the world
and i'm watching uh commercial they're
talking about the turkey
avocado sandwiches delicious
it sounds delicious
that's a delicious sandwich if you take
thuman's [__] oven roasted turkey and
you slice that [__] thin and you
get a nice avocado and smear it you put
some jalapenos maybe a piece of
provolone yeah that's a [__] dynamic
sandwich right there but when you go to
[__] uh subway or subway yeah you
taste that sandwich and it's that
[__] turkey salami [__] how are you
gonna eat
how do you call this a spicy italian
this is a spicy [__] turkey this
ain't no spicy town all that you leave
there and an hour later you're burping
[__] cold cuts like a [__]
you're not supposed to be burping
[__] cold cards never yeah so that's
the reason why i don't go to the subway
i know that jared said he lost weight
with subway wait five years from now
he's got a hemorrhoid the size of
[__] mouth euleptics coming out of
his [__] yeah because all that [__]
will [__] kill you and the lettuce is
petrified sometimes it's just a little
petrified you know
you even see the [__] people that
work in subway they forget to put their
gloves on
that's what that's the worst thing from
customer service in restaurants is to an
all-time [__] and that's not even
customer service at a restaurant it's
customer service [__] anywhere you
walk into these places and these kids
just look at you like you're a [__]
three-headed [__] monster you know
just either help me you don't [__]
help me yeah the store is looking to
[__] spend a dollar and i look at
who's working there and how they treat
you and i've always said that in this
economy right now customer service is
just going to prevail yeah you know
everybody has a cheap price look at
[__] uh amazon you could do is uh
you could [__] do
amazon for [__] nothing yeah go on
get delivery to your house you don't
have to leave shipping is free stay home
and mine your [__] business and
that's it you know what i'm saying do
you think it's commission because like
best buy in all those places they don't
make commission anymore so what is their
incentive to sell what best best buy is
any of those electronic places any store
i don't know i have any stores that give
that work on commission anymore do you
yeah people work on i used to work at
[__] footlocker that's what i'm
saying i'm i think in the past but i
know at least at the big electronic
stores they don't work on commissions so
that's why they don't know anything and
they don't actually it was on louie the
other night the other night he uh he
went into a store and a salesman didn't
know anything about it and then when he
got when louie didn't want to help him
out he uh the salesman tripped him and
it was hilarious but it brought up a
good point that what's their incentive
to sell it's why in at good restaurants
when servers can make money you're gonna
get good service
at least in my experience i don't know
what do you think the [__] are you
talking about people i don't know man
i've been up all night well if you go to
[__] a nice restaurant and they know
you're gonna [__] listen you should
always [__] tip big a lot of like my
mother my mother would get into a cab
and throw the [__] at 20. just
to know where she stood with the
[__] before she even put the
pedal to the metal [__] sucker you know
so they know where you stand you know
where you stand you go to a bar
sometimes the bar is packed you throw
that bartender a [__] ten spot and a
cr and a bud and a rock or something
they could stand around me yelling me me
me me me you're gonna still get the
[__] cocktail first that's old-school
type mentality yeah that's church of
what's happening now you walk in there
you give that [__] guy a bud you slip
in his hand like a soldier
and you see what happens speaking of
[__] church what's happening now
let's break over for some [__] uh
jesus [__] cookies here i got these
uh things last night they're like one
two thousand grams of [__] reefer and
a little these are the new church of
what's happened now uh is that an edible
yeah these are little edibles uh holy
[__] they're really uh
they're really uh what do you call those
jolly ranchers what you call them oh
good lord you [__] take them like
this and right now if you're at home get
on your hands and knees so i can throw a
[__] blessing on your [__]
you know uh jesus took the [__] juice
passed around his friends and said drink
for me
the holy blood this is my [__] blood
the new and everlasting blood
drink of it and you'll live for [__]
ever and then he took the after dinner
he took the [__] bread and he broke
and he gave it to his disciples and said
take this all of you and drink of it or
eat of it this is my body the true and
everlasting body of mad [__]
flavor holy so here it is boom the
church boom throw it
that's how we're running here today
where's these cats come see your dad
your [__] come here mama now these cats
are coming out lee's here today lee
would you get a hooker last night or
something you got the [__] you came
in here you put them a look on them you
know what i'm saying i'm sorry man
usually they like me i don't know what's
going on
come on come on gregory
you don't want to say hello to the
camera [__] sucker
and i'm going to show you this regret
this is my girl
oh great's great
this is my great great guys
here's my little girl
she's not that little either she's my
[__] 10.
i love her with all my heart this is my
little great grace say hello [__]
say hello gregory
what's happening
i know i'm not in the mic leaf so what i
turned it up i turned it up man they get
it jesus christ
they got to see what the beautiful cat
is i can't help mike say hello mama now
gray has an interesting story right
because when i first came over here she
was like living in this room mostly yeah
because gray
used to live outside and when i moved
here gray started coming up the stairs
and saying hello scratching the door in
the mornings and [__] my other cats will
get [__] pissed yeah but then gray
got attacked by this douchebag [__]
catwalk scene last night
he ripped open her little back huh
so uh
i couldn't find it she wouldn't come
home so me and my wife went hunting for
grain we found it around the corner
and we brought it back and and the
landlord downstairs took it to the vet
but the problem was
once she came back she wasn't allowed to
go back outside okay she's already got
dogs downstairs
that's right this is my little girl
so i brought her up i didn't want her to
leave she had grown up around here she
knows the ins and outs she's not allowed
to go out no more
besides i couldn't have her out look at
her she's my little black and white girl
who says i hate black people
that's like [__]
i'm not good guys we're here with queen
some beautiful sunday this is like
really a run-through today i want to
just get out and i'll see you guys last
week was just a run-through we're
probably going to start tomorrow
officially correctly yeah we'll start
we'll start tomorrow and like people
who've been asking you can watch this on
stickum it's if you just go to joey's
page like a couple hours later it takes
it's like youtube it takes a while to
upload it everything will be there uh
the other one we didn't put up on itunes
it was like a kind of a test this one
will put up
and it'll be up probably tomorrow and
everything will be up the day after and
just a reminder we're looking for
opening songs and we got a couple and we
got some saying oh use this song use
that song what we want is you guys to
make us a song without any else anyone
else's music and send it to church of
what's happening now pod at gmail dot
com
do it to joey's twitter at mad flavor do
it to me at least say it
just give it give it give us whatever
you got man just do what you got put it
down
[__] get a ukulele you know what i
listen to guys you know the [__]
style
of music i listen to i listen to a lot
of [__] crazy [__]
and that's weird man
i appreciate the people who did listen
sending me some emails and saying that
they've been listening to uh aerosmith
rocks because like i told you once i
told you a million times guys it's one
of the best albums we're gonna start
counting down every time i get on or
every couple of days i'm gonna drop a
new album on you and there's thousands
of them i mean listen
uh an album is not just ten songs
it's the [__] order the way they put
it on there the way you could [__]
feel it going on there
uh led zeppelin ii was one of my
favorite [__] albums because how they
dropped it on there uh look at this oh
watch
that's okay she's a good lady put her on
there uh pink floyd the wall pink floyd
animals got four songs you know uh uh
allison's chains dirt it's not just
about ten great songs it's also how they
put it together another great album is
judas priest british steel you don't
have to be old to be wise it's the
fourth song on the second side just to
let you know where the [__] strength
is coming from you know what i'm saying
do you want to play it
but you don't have to be old to be wise
[__] player judas priest 80.
i got the vapor pen out
like a doctor
what's going on great look at gray came
out for some [__] catnip who wouldn't
i gotta hide this because if not i'm
telling you this [__] look at these
bugs on the cabin this is the best [__]
in the world
pete peck greens
catnip buds look at her losing mine
come on gregory
gregory don't [__] around no
what happened no no i'm saying she
doesn't [__] around yeah those [__]
candies are good i might have to eat
another one you know here we go
[Music]
you got another thing in common or
whatever i can't deal with that [__]
this is a badass song right here but
anyway let's go back to arrows from the
rocks play the whole [__] album we're
gonna go over a couple songs here before
i gotta go to church let me tell you
something i'm going on my second body of
christ compels you
do you have a specific song you want to
play from it
let's open up with the uh first one back
in the [__] saddle again
[__]
and where's my facebook people [__]
facebook too many christians are on
[__] facebook they really he said
that did something happen he just you
just saw it and i could just tell i
could just tell facebook is like
i don't know it's like going to the
business part of town that's closed on
[__] sounds like the business bar as
opposed to like the fun bar twitter you
go on twitter put a syringe up there
somebody will come back with a [__]
grenade at one in the morning yeah of
course you know queen is always alive
and kick them
don't forget if you want to save your
lungs i hear the eureka vapor pen
novo organic
this is the crazy thing about this song
everybody's like well i've been being a
kid listening to people calling
smith's not gonna come back they're
gonna break up they're on heroin
kick this this is how they come to kick
[Music]
go to the next jam what's the name of it
they don't have the whole album here
they don't have to get it oh here it is
okay who do you think you're dealing
with doug they got evil smith everything
on youtube it's a last child
listen to [__] joe perry's guitar
i'm last child okay this is what i'm
talking about
this is it this is pure
heroine in your [__] soul they don't
even have music like this no more
because nobody will take the chance
nobody will go to chinatown pick up a
bag of number two
you don't even have to shoot in your van
do two little bumps you see the [__]
devil he's on a harmonic and a [__]
tambourine here we go cricket
[Music]
town
okay you got the worst one you can't the
lyrics enough
there's already there's always uh uh uh
and i'll tell you one thing about
aerosmith it's not just
rocks that's a great album get your
wings the one before there's a great
album draw the [__] line is a
great app
the one uh even the last aerosmith album
where uh joe i think joe perry left no
no no no yeah joe perry left first joe
perry went on and started a band for a
while it was called the joe perry
project and i seen him open up heart
opened up for them in 81
kevin radios
what are you [__] [__]
it's 1981 kevin hart heart the [__]
fat chick in the skinny blonde chick
[__] kevin
here's what i gotta deal with where is
it where's last child the good addition
here
i'm trying to [__] take these guys
into a psychological journey all right
let me get
me [__] around here i want these guys
to learn something why i think the
church or what's happening now is coming
up twice a week people are [__]
confused i want you [__] to
stop what you're [__] looking like
everybody else you gotta be the
individual
be yourself no more sheep allowed blast
that [__] thing listen to this
[Music]
oh [__] oh
[__] it's on youtube
[Music]
go to amazon go to your grandmother's
house look through her album collection
if she ain't got [__] aerial smith's
rocks your grandmother was not a [__]
[__] so maybe that's why she's
over there alone and [__] going to bingo
with the [__] priest and a bunch of
other ugly women who what the [__] am i
talking about
look at super bad came in for some
reason my allergies have been bothering
me oh they're awful i don't want people
to think that my nose is leaking because
i was out doing [__] bumps in some
[__] puerto rican it's so funny man
you know i did coke for 30 years and the
funniest thing is that i always think of
this one dealer i had here because it
was always such a blast to cop him i
didn't meet him
i met him in a parking lot in hollywood
you met him in the park yeah like we
were just talking one night he came up
to me this mexican guy and he's like you
know anybody looking for [__]
and i was like yeah me
[__] idea you knocked on the right
door and he talked to me in spanish west
away
all right he opened up his hand he had a
coke rock in his hand i took it you know
i go how much he gets before he even
gave it to me he wanted to make sure i
wasn't a cop so you know these [__]
momos now excuse me are you a cop this
[__] just took a coke rock and
put it in my nose
he didn't play with you wow and you
didn't fight it you didn't like he just
put that little rock in your nose that
make sure that you weren't a [__] cop
okay then he did business with him
so he gave me the coke rock and he goes
listen if you want a cop go by uh
western and sunset there there's like an
old uh building or whatever the [__]
there is there mcdonald's and there's a
burger king on the corner you ever go
over there there's like yeah it's like
and it's really empty at night that area
you think that western sunset would be
busier but it's kind of weird
so he goes just driver would i go do i
beat you do i beep you do i call he goes
no no just go to western the sunset i'm
there after 11. don't worry drive around
and i'll find you i might drive around
i'll find you yeah and sure enough you
get the [__] western the sunset you
drive down the block go around there's
like a thai massage place you go you
make a left and you come right back to
get to sunset and you drive back the
other direction going west and all of a
sudden like i passed western and i'm
driving and i look out my rearview
mirror and i see this [__] mexican
guy chasing me
like chasing me and i'm like what the
[__] i go oh my god that's him
so i pulled right over on sunset he
would come up to the car window
go hey how you doing in spanish get in
the way what's going on and then he
[__] just put a rocket coat in my
nose while i was driving and then he go
what do you got and i give him the money
and he go open your hand he put the
[__]
coke rock in your hand you put in the
middle compartment
head home before the [__] cops come
out that was hysterical another night
one of the funniest cops i ever had i
was living in jersey he was like uh
wasn't 94 it was the late 80s
and uh
me and my buddies were hanging hold on
watch this far here
uh that's a good fart right there these
cats will blow after this
oh that's a good breakfast blend oh
thank god your fans on as they call it
so uh we went over i never forget this
and my buddy goes listen we're in the
city why don't we just [__] cop in
the city
so
we pull over and there's this uh there's
this uh
black hooker and she's kind of cute my
buddy pulls up the and she's like what
the [__] can we get some blow and the
[__] is like right here
i got it my buddy goes so how much for a
gram we didn't even know we had not
nothing we knew how much a gram was in
those days my buddy goes what can i get
for a hundred bucks okay that's what he
asked her
and he goes she goes give me the money
and she he gave the money and also she
goes put out your hand
and he pulled out his hand he was both
of them and he put out both hands and
she just went in her purse and started
emptying these little crack vials and
[__] blow like 20 of them she's like
jesus and we're like what the [__] we
didn't know what crack was we were still
confused it had to be like 84 or
something okay 90 80. and i we look at
him like what the [__] is this and she's
like that's crack [__] you know you
just got yourself some crack and we're
like how do you do this and she's like
you gotta smoke it and we're like where
do we smoke it and that [__] had a pipe
that she was smoking we gave it like 20
bucks bought the pipe for me and [__]
i'll never forget i smoked it the next
day i had to brush my teeth with [__]
gasoline oh god
that's something i've never gone into
just anything other than uh other than
wheat i've never got that but you don't
need [__] nothing all you need is you
don't even need [__] alcohol i don't
like drinking that much man nah i've
never seen you drink i don't like
[__] drinking either and people that
get drunk sometimes they just
i don't know how to expect it sometimes
i don't know how to like i went to
denver and i was doing the show with joe
and we're having a great time and i had
a great time and done with the people
and next time i went to the ufc you know
that the mad flavor where you made me
when i'm talking to the kids oh yeah and
the girls dancing in right so they're
talking to these [__] kids watching
the frankie edgar fight
and right away a girl comes over
right some [__] drunk girl like
trying to light a cigarette yeah i hate
drunk
they're the worst
now i'm watching i got my eye on the
[__] camera the cam the phone the tv
is right there uh-huh i'm [__]
watching this i'm watching i'm watching
this you know it's like a minute in the
rounds of five minutes right yes five
rounds in this fight this [__] popped
out in the second round and sat there
next to me and started asking me
questions and poking me like pokemon and
she's like you have to walk over and
meet my husband i'm like listen i'm
watching the [__] fight i'm surprised
you let her go past two seconds no i'm
one bro i had my eyeball on the [__]
fight she could talk all she wants you
know it's not being rude or whatever i'm
watching the fight yeah somebody gave me
a ticket to come in here and watch the
fight
you know we go down there into fights
i usually don't want joe to go by
himself so i go at 4 45 with him so i
sit there the whole [__] night oh by
six o'clock the edible just kicked in
i'm [__] cracked and you know i'm on
my way so i like to walk around yeah you
just can't eat those [__] hot dogs
and pretzels you walk around at most
these arenas today they have real food
yeah yeah sometimes i just want to
stretch my legs i had the knee surgery
so i went to this corner
and the kids came up to me and they were
the kids were fun because it was in
between fights i had a good time talking
to him it was the [__] lady when she
came over and the lady was cute and i
had nothing to do with it i'm watching
the fight and she's poking me and she's
asking me if i have a lighter and who do
you like we're going for this and i'm
like listen this is a great fight we'll
talk afterwards she said starts telling
me that her husband wants to meet me
to walk down with her to her seat jesus
and i'm like they're not gonna let me in
the area without a ticket yes yes they
will they'll let you in the area they'll
let you in the area she's giving me all
this [__] i'm like lady and also the
third round starts yeah and she's still
[__] hawking me and i go lady please
after [__] two runs i had to say
something i wasn't being rude i'm not
lady [__] please can i watch this so
she ends up going to the bathroom
so i'm outside and usually when somebody
gets knocked the [__] out or whatever or
at the end of the fight i'm out of there
because i don't want to walk out of
there with 90 people
i want to walk out of it with like three
or four people and be outside i go
outside yeah you know
so uh the edgar [__] fight ended i
run outside and also my phone starts
ringing because i had gone with uh
duncan or ahri or all of us you know we
were all calling each other doug benson
was with me so was uh brandon welsh
so we all were on the phone waiting
so sure enough the phone uh calls and
it's and it's uh doug or joe and they're
like hey where are you and i'm like i'm
in front of the place i'm not [__]
kidding you lee a guy comes up to me
behind me and right in my head goes
da
lucy snorebush right oh my god i'm like
can you hold on for one second because i
can't hear them yeah he's like ah lucy
snowboarding and he keeps yelling lucy
[__] snowbush
i finally go hey you [__] [__] sucker
can't you see i'm on the [__] phone
you [__] douchebag that's the worst
what the [__] is wrong with you are you
that [__] drunk i go let me finish
the car i swear to god let me finish the
[__] conversation and then i'll do
whatever the [__] you want yeah lee do
you know i turn around to talk to joe or
doug and again the guy yells in my ear
that's why i don't like alcohol and i
was like are you [__] kidding me i
mean and that's the [__] that gets me
off this dog listen man in my life
even when i was a child i never
approached nobody i approached julia
serving and i think i'd blinked the
[__] uh richard gere in the studio to
see if he would suck my dick but
you know somebody's on the phone i mean
the way i was [__] raised somebody's
on the phone you wait for them to get
the [__] off the phone or you do what
the [__] you got to do i don't know who
they're talking to you see somebody on
the phone that's just a polite thing to
do
is uh you know to see who the [__]
they're talking to just say excuse me
not even you're on the [__] phone
yeah but these people are coming to my
ear and i enjoy doing the podcast and i
enjoy doing everything the [__] i do
leave not i wouldn't do it i don't do
this [__] i don't do this because i
want to do this i do this because i like
talking to people i like doing stand-up
comedy i love doing this [__] but that's
the one [__] part that just kills you
when you try to tell somebody hey you
know when you come up to me after one of
my shows i'll basically do anything with
you yeah out you're out there probably
for at least an hour after two hours
talking to people i don't i love it i
love to i want to know where you came
from what made you drive you know people
say to me hey man the story about this
helped me go through this this morning
we're talking about being a fat [__]
like me and trying to lose weight all
this helps people connect with you for a
certain reason yeah and that's what i
always knew like for years i didn't
connect with people because of my county
if you don't have to see me five years
ago you were probably thought i was
funny or whatever but you weren't going
to go home and look me up it wasn't
until i started talking about mugging
hookers and and you know but with the
mugging hookers i also shared other you
know positive [__] experiences yeah
and i only mugged one hook i know only
one one one time then you feel fine you
get one yeah i don't i i never like
doing all that [__] you know
sometimes
when something bad happens to you in
your life and you get angry at society
you're angry at yourself you get angry
at the [__] god that you worship
whatever the [__]
you you tend to do [__] that you don't
really want to do you just do it maybe
the [__] cover up the pain maybe
that's what i did at that time you know
what i'm saying lee yeah lee what's
going on if you're going to play music
for me don't make me have to [__]
play music over here and me switch this
[__] up this one i told you this
before we did the podcast that we got to
figure out how i could play music in
mayan because i know this music i know
all these songs and i know where to go
all right i'll plug the next one i'll
plug it into yours and you can yeah
because i gotta control the music over
here no i can't give the people what the
[__] they want you know what i'm saying
all right you're like you're i mean yeah
you know the music so you got no i gotta
love the music because i gotta give
these [__] something to get
fired up about i mean this morning i
played a couple songs but they weren't
uh oh i'm getting [__] up on those
candies oh really
it may be time for another one [__]
it's the lord's name and it's it's not
even 7am yeah not even 7. who gives a
[__] man listen
this has always been a great jam for me
i always like black sabbath into the
void
you know the first time i bought master
reality
i wouldn't [__] listen to it i
listened to it like once or twice
and i was scared
uh
and i never [__] uh
you know liked it again and then finally
as i got older one day
i [__] uh listened to master reality
and i really dug it again put on a
little master reality see what you got
for them
which one blacks episode into the void
[__] yeah all right so i'm gonna play it
for us first see if you like it and then
if if it sounds good i'll play for them
listen to this torture yeah here we go
baby all right so i'll play for them
[Music]
first time
uh
[Music]
no i don't like
oh no well not even that but even like
the extra system there's a new movie
coming up where the jews are are are
taking over people have you seen that
like uh
[Music]
no the devil goes crazy
here we go
[Music]
and now now he has a reality show or had
a reality show what do you think about
that when the rock stars you grew up
with her doing reality shows on mtv
listen brother
[Music]
ah
you do your best work
when you don't give a [__] yeah as we've
noticed
the best work
when you don't give a [__] okay what
that means is
uh
you know you listen to the first four
albums of somebody and you're like [__]
this is tremendous and then what happens
is they drove they got a little money
thrown at them and then now there's
hungry listen everybody should have a
great first [__] out it's the second
album that [__] kills you yeah
everybody should have uh what was the
question
no i was talking about about the like
like we talked about last week how uh
the lead singer of our smith was on
american idol and aussie had an mtv show
like just when you see your heroes doing
stuff like that like you're talking
about they did heroin and they didn't
care and they did all this awesome music
well now they got money thrown at them
yeah and and
you know i was an aussie fan when
[__] uh up to black sabbath
and i was an aussie fan for the first
two or three hours then it went into a
different direction he was barking at
the moon he was doing all this [__] and
it didn't uh really catch on for me no
more but it's like us right now you know
i come on here for for a long time
from uh for a long time i uh
could stand up for ten [__] years out
here and i did stand up for five before
that
and i got moderate success i got into
some movies and stuff like that
uh i i did a podcast with felicia i did
the joe rogan podcast a bunch and i
realized that you know what i had
nothing to [__] lose when you have
nothing to lose in your life that's the
best position you're in so i told these
stories that were all real about my life
growing up that i would tell people for
years and they go dawg why don't you
talk about that on [__] stage
you know talk about these stories on
stage and i go dog i can't say this
i finally opened up my soul to these
people yeah and they took the ride with
me you know uh i do this podcast in the
mornings especially this one i do the
one with felicia i do joe's and duncan's
i love doing them but i wanted to do
this podcast at church of what's
happening now to let people know what
the [__] was in my head yeah you know
and i will tell you something i don't
care how many sponsors i get or whatever
i'm still going to beat me because i
have nothing to lose
there's people that money change them
and when the money comes in they get
like uh what do you call that [__] like
they they sent themselves they watch
what the [__] they're doing because they
don't want to lose that i.e jon jones
two weeks ago he's a [__] champion he
has everything to lose by going in that
ring with chaos and nothing in the game
and nothing to gain and that's a lot of
people understand everybody's sitting
there putting jon jones down why are you
putting this kid down somebody's calling
out your challenge who has nothing to
lose who came off a [__] loss has
fought nobody
uh you know
he's coming off a [__] loss you know
at least come up and fight somebody at
205 before you call out jon jones and
the public is like oh jon jones a [__]
no he's this becomes a business this
isn't like i told tripoli and the punch
drunk dudes this isn't two puerto ricans
at white castle
this isn't about just fighting because
i'm tougher than you it's a business
he's got two daughters and a wife and
you know a family and whatever the [__]
he's got you know he makes mistakes like
everybody else but when you have a lot
more to lose you protect
what you have you know when you have
nothing to lose like me i mean [__] it
you know what i survived all these years
and what i got i don't need [__]
money money's not gonna do nothing for
me at this point in the game i'm happy
just being [__] me yeah we have a
great time we fart all women walk into
that [__] swamp ass
you know what i'm saying so
uh
that's what happens you know when when
ozzie got that reality show when i heard
about it i'm not gonna lie to you i grew
up on aussie bro if it wasn't for ozzie
i'd be [__] dead yeah i believed you
know master reality i believe sabotage i
was telling uh duncan and burke that i
would go home at night you know just to
move on to the next level of my life
after i was a kid and my mother died i
would go home and do a hit ass and
listen to uh
to uh what do you call that [__] uh
black sabbath sabotage
i would really listen to it and see what
he was saying so when he got the reality
show absolutely i turned it in i turned
it on and turned it and i should have
turned those [__] in
yeah part of me broke my heart that was
my childhood idol and i see him now with
black [__] nails and eye makeup on
and they say he's got a ghost
[__] singer or whatever that doesn't
bother me i i i loved him when he was
john osborne ozzy is what the american
public bought into okay you follow me i
knew when he was john i was born from oh
wow england i'm not that i knew him yeah
well yeah
i never heard this one before i've only
heard of his real [__] name that's
why your [__] name his name is john
ozzy osbourne or whatever the [__]
so
uh that that's when i was into him it's
like anybody else man you know uh
an athlete uh it comes into the league
he's [__] great and also when he gets
15 million dollars a year he's not gonna
dive on the floor no more he's not gonna
be larry bird that's why so many people
admire larry bird because the point of
his [__] career he would chase a ball
and scrape his elbow and go into the
stands you know there's some people that
you you've seen major league the movie
yeah you know when he would say what
does the third baseman say i'm not going
to uh oh i don't know i'm not going to
pick up the ball because i might
ricochet off this face
people don't you know they worry about
that you have to live your life without
a [__] safety net once you have that
safety then that's what happens you're
not the same person anymore i love doing
this [__] i really do believe because
the reason why i do these podcasts and i
talk the [__] i do is because there's a
lot of young kids right now that uh that
are walking around the same way i did a
21 or 22 or 28 or 30 confused
and i you know i'm 49 not lee and i
swear to god with the knowledge i have
i wish i had uh 10 more years i wish i
could add 10 years to my life but you
know what the sad scenario is i can't
yeah and for years when i was a young
guy and i was out there doing what i was
doing all the people come to me and talk
to me and give me advice and i always go
go [__] yourself you don't know what
you're talking about and now
they did know what they were talking
about and i don't think the wishes
people take from me what uh what they
can
and we're going to finish this joint
we're going to get the [__] out of here
for the day that's it
how long have we been on for uh just
under an hour
just under an hour yeah it feels like
two [__] years i know right we have
uh we've had 1500 people listen to that
all right sunday for church for a sunday
morning yeah and they're getting ready
for church and at least you got to spend
an hour with uncle joey smoke a bone we
ate some edibles i introduced you to the
cats we talked about a couple
interesting subjects about i farted you
farts on a [__] podcast and you're
here with that intensity because a lot
of people thought it was real quick
what are you going to do you know what
i'm saying but it's beautiful to start
the week off with you and you know
that's another reason people always say
to me oh joey you don't work sunday
nights i got a couple reasons i don't
work something that i [__] hate
working sunday on the seventh day god
rested and made [__] black sabbath
and number two because i want to do a
podcast on mondays i like being home on
mondays i like being focused on mondays
because it sets me up for the rest of
the [__] week yeah you know we're
going to have my friends calling him
we're going to have a little little
lubes call in i'm going to have my
friend bill's calling we're going to
have the north bergen minute we get to
tell stories when i rob the gas station
with the water pistol [__] like that i'm
going to have my boy joey fulato call in
so we got a lot of [__] going on
tomorrow we got another one yeah you
know and i appreciate you guys turning
this on on sunday man you know i i
didn't get up at five for [__] my
health here i mean nobody's cutting a
check i got a few [__] to smoke
dope with you guys i know half years at
the house going [__] it i'm going to
roll up a bone with my uncle joey and
we're going to smoke through osmosis
that's what we do here
look at the [__] cat she hasn't moved
in and out no she's she's a part of it
what are you doing
huh
what are you doing now i know a lot of
people out there are excited for i don't
know i don't know if you watch do you
watch breaking bad
no no you don't is it why would you
watch breaking bad when you lived
breaking bad that was my question are
any of these shows or movies or anything
like that anything like reality or is it
just it's just all fiction and it's just
it's just nothing like that at all man
you know they use
they use consultants and [__] like all
right i was watching uh what's the show
i watch on friday nights or whatever uh
uh sons of anarchy i have a few friends
on sunset and i watch the [__] show
you know so you're going to tell your
wife about killing people your old lady
knows about killing people you know i
don't like when they all sit together
and they vote because if i go let's [__]
lee up the ass i got to vote
those eight people could take you to
[__] jail i don't like talking with
more than two [__] people in the room
okay
so there's little things like that that
you really have to think about and say
what the [__] you know i was watching an
episode of sopranos in a hotel when i
was in sacramento and i was the one when
they were gonna shoot somebody so tony
soprano
told
uh
uh the guy with the hair and sharipa
to take care of this guy and then that
guy went and told paulie and then paulie
hired a guy and then he went down and
told somebody else so there was seven
[__] people involved in this hit
seven people that means there's seven
people get pulled over and have an ounce
of blown and have a story for the cops
okay is that realistic no if i was gonna
kill somebody and i was a gangster i go
to my underboss or whatever and go
listen this guy's got to go there's two
years two years is better than [__]
seven okay so i've never understood that
concept when i watch a tv show i'm like
that's gotta be a [__] [__] it's
gotta be [__] okay nobody would have
a [__] we're gonna we're gonna move
guns here's seven of us no the hierarchy
is gonna talk about and the underwingers
are gonna stay outside
it's the
[__] for them not to know okay you know
the more people that know your crime the
more people that can testify against you
you know if 80s is like yeah we kill
[__] joey dears 80 years at one time
you're [__] living on our night shows
you don't know when that [__] mark is
gonna come in that's what number uh
that's uh rule number four the church
what's happening now karma's a
[__] if you do it expect a
receipt
really because life will always give you
a [__] receipt so i you know when i
watch those type of shows and how they
do it breaking bad i've never really
watched i've never gotten into it oh
it's amazing that's amazing no i know i
just got to get into it from the
beginning i'm like most people once the
show ends i'll get the [__] dvd a
friend will give me the box set and i'll
watch them without commercials and i can
really get into it i just uh you know
lee man
you know uh i always love sports i grew
up on sports jesus christ i went to five
star basketball camp i was gonna go to
saint anthony's in jersey city when the
hurleys were there with us the little
early kids were kids and i knew the old
man you know and uh
i love playing basketball you know i
love watching
college basketball i love watching pro
football and i would watch baseball but
at 16 my mother died and i had to make a
hustle i had to make a living so i
learned how to watch what's [__]
important yeah everybody wants to watch
a [__] game but this is what needs to
be done yeah so i i watch sports today i
really don't know what's going on
because now i understand you can live
without sports when i see these guys
walking around with their [__]
jerseys on sundays i'm like really guy
but that's what they're into i'm into
weed they're into that's what they're
into so i can't be mad at them for being
me i'm into the team that covers the
[__] spread if i'm gonna watch a game
i want to watch the [__] game i'm a
cuban jew i got a hat that says minus
seven on it
broncos or [__] charges uh or lakers
and all that [__] although i do like to
watch the lakers so
it's really weird i like sports but
you realize that uh you have so many
[__] different things going on you
just can't pay attention to everything
you want to read a book and try to get
knowledge coming in you try to write you
know now you got to keep up with movies
you got to keep up with all these
[__] things it's weird because a lot
of people always ask me about movies and
we've always gotten the rogan uh
bandwagon whenever i get on the rogan
thing we start talking about 70s movies
in the 70s and you know what they're
great but they're a little slow for most
people you know we're from a [__] we
wanted situation
from the church or the new church what's
happening now we want it now so
it's kind of [__] tough to uh to uh
to wait for that stuff when you watch a
movie from the 70s your patience level
has to be unbelievable you got to be
really stoned because you're so used to
explosives and [__] happening
conversations are quicker
so uh the movie for this week i'm going
to give you guys that's a [__]
classic what can i give him lee a nice
70s
that's a great [__] movie that i
realized last week guys
i'm gonna give you a movie the martial
arts genre
see and here's the problem with it uh
that a lot of people
they released all those bruce lee movies
with different titles so it was releases
the chinese connection is now fist to
fury okay the way i look at it is the
fist of fury was the first one chinese
connection is when his teacher gets
killed and he avenges his teacher and he
[__] [__] up the japanese school and
he hangs him let me tell you something
if you have time this weekend please
watch the second bruce lee move which is
the chinese connection okay when they
kill his teacher when they poison the
teacher that is one i got it on dvr i
got it on dvr whenever i'm a little
depressed i watch it watch that movie
watch the passion on bruce lee's face
that was his second movie he was still
tight with steve mcqueen he was calling
for acting watch that [__] movie guys
chinese connection with bruce lee that's
all that's it for today i don't know
what else to [__] tell you what do
you think lee did we forget anything no
man uh uh since i'm kind of busy i'm
going to do it today i'm going to build
the facebook page for the show and why
we want all you guys to go there and
comment on the movie talk about the
movie talk about the music just we want
this to be a community of people talk
about the [__] movement the
church of what's happening now you're
getting ours back today i gave you rule
number one which is mind your [__]
business rule number four calm as a
[__] don't do it unless you want
a [__] receipt
and that's what we're trying to do we're
trying to put your [__]
together so when you get out of the
house listen i can do this podcast at 10
o'clock at night i could do this at
three in the morning with lee i do it
now
because what i'm trying to do is get you
ready for the [__] day it's a
beautiful day to be alive go out there
go out there
[__] do what you need to do get your
dick sucked go out there and exercise go
out there get some sunlight eat good
enjoy your family today because this is
only one life man [__] all that nonsense
stay black what else we got this week
nothing man uh we're gonna be back
tomorrow labor day send us send us some
emails a church of what's happening now
pod at gmail.com send us questions
anything you want to ask joey and we
want to read it on air man i mean you're
part of this with us and and just send
it and we'll make the show as long as we
can if we have stuff to talk about we'll
go two or three hours you know lee is
jewish so for all you jews you gotta
[__] compadre i'm bored i'm a cuban
jew
you know the whole [__] thing we're
bringing the yamaka back
oh one last fart that was three farts in
a podcast who gives you
that type of entertainment huh that time
we're coming out tomorrow
uh one at the same time six o'clock six
a.m let's do six a.m tomorrow see you
[__] at 6am tomorrow don't
forget take it with you i love you guys
for watching and uh stay black
[__] bye guys